okay i think i have this okay
so here's the thing here's the thing
episode number five
of i'm i'm all over the place i'm like a
foot away like like two three feet away
from the microphone
episode number five of one division it
introduced evan peters quicksilver at
the end of the episode and all of our
minds were blown
and we were like how in the world does
quicksilver from the fox universe appear
in the marvel cinematic universe does
she just yank him in from a different
dimension
is it somebody messing with her
something along those lines okay let's
wind the clock back a little bit i have
largely
been against the idea that mephisto is
the person pulling all the strings but i
think you guys are right and i think he
is but the difference here is i don't
think it's just mephisto i think in the
marvel cinematic
marvel cinematic universe mephisto and
nightmare are one in the same person now
here's a little bit of history here when
it comes to these characters right
because you guys need to understand this
don't understand this video right so
why the clock back in marvel comics
mephisto and nightmare are what we call
hell lords they rule their own
dimensions technically
nightmare is the ruler of the dream
dimension and mephisto is the ruler of
just one of the many
iterations of hell that exists
originally all you had
was just the dark dimension the place
where dormammu dwells and where he kind
of conquers and rules everything
somewhere along the line there was some
kind of a major conflict and the dark
dimension was split into what we call
the splinter dimensions and then
humanity because we were just dreaming
up horrible terrible
freaky things or because we were
imagining some place of just
torment and suffering we effectively
imagined mephisto as the ruler of hell
i.e satan and nightmare into existence
right that's just basically how it's
always been and they've existed ever
since now they're only a couple
of people who rule these different
little splinter realms or these little
little splinter dimensions but they are
at all times waging war against each
other trying to amass an army and then
trying to conquer the other splinter
realms and then eventually expand their
influence out into
the rest of the multiverse and then
conquer everything now the whole idea
behind this is let's say
that mephisto and nightmare are one in
the same in the marvel cinematic
universe there are two concepts in
marvel comics that have been combined
into one in the marvel cinematic
universe now let's say
that evan peters quicksilver is in the
mcu right now
but that's not actually what's going on
that mephisto nightmare whatever it is
we can call him
you know knight fisto whatever you want
to call him but he's basically messing
with wanda's mind
that when wanda looks at quicksilver she
sees aaron taylor johnson but we as the
audience
see evan peters we see him as he really
is now the question is
why why would mephisto and nightmare or
the you know night fist
why would he go through all of this why
would he go through
all of that just to target juan to max
him off what's her significance why is
she important in all of this it's the
white phoenix of the crown effect
right okay so side step one division for
a second go back to 1981. and
in marvel comics because our adventures
issue number 27 written by chris
claremont this was a story that gave us
the original origin of jean grey right
it was an old black and white comic
looked like it was hand drawn by some
kid in high school but it was really
really cool the idea in this origin
story was it was designed to answer the
question
why jean grey became the phoenix in the
first place right the phoenix force
being this
omniversal force of energy that
represents all life that currently does
has ever and will ever exist in the in
the whole multiverse and the question
was why did jean grey become a host for
the phoenix this story answers that
question and saying that when jean grey
was a little girl that her friend
annie died and that when her friend
annie died she let out this kind of
psychic sos
and two people picked up on it the first
one to pick up on it was charles xavier
who realized holy cow this girl is
powerful i should
bring her into the xavier institute and
she can join my x-men right the second
person to pick up on it was the phoenix
and the phoenix was just like damn what
the hell was that
right so like it ends up analyzing jean
grey and then realizes jean grey is in
fact
the perfect host for the phoenix force
that she can achieve the level of the
white phoenix of the crown which is
basically what happens when you're a
perfect host and you can use
100 of the phoenix's power you
effectively become god
now i think that's what's going on here
somewhere along the line
mephisto slash nightmare became aware of
wanda's existence
and realized she's the perfect host
right she's the perfect person for them
to achieve their goals
because we keep looking at the idea of
mephisto and nightmare or
you know night fists or whatever we keep
looking at them as like a new concept
somebody that just popped up what if
they didn't what if they've been there
this entire time and just been
locked away or just like held prisoner
you know kind of confined in what is
more or less like a multiversal cosmic
jail or something like that and by
whatever manner and whatever
means they were free or they managed to
get out or something along those lines
right when steven strange was
blinked out of existence that all the
different charms and enchantments that
were designed to keep them locked in
place
disappeared as well so they are
basically free to kind of get out and do
their own thing and as they're going
through and as
as nightmares slash mephistos doing his
thing or whatever it is he becomes aware
of wanda right now let's say that this
happens now in marvel comics if you go
when you read captain america volume 3
in the 1990s there's a story that i
think takes place between
issues 8 and 12 where captain america is
possessed by nightmare and the idea is
that nightmare wants to essentially
bring the whole world into like a
walking sleep right to more or less
conquer the world in his own weird way
and so what if that's what's going on
here what if nightmare slash mephisto
mephisto
nightmare or whatever what if in the
aftermath of like infinity war and
avengers endgame when wanda's brought
back into existence
what if what happened there is he
appeared to her in a dream
she didn't really make a deal with the
devil or anything like that but he
appeared to her in a dream
and set her on the path of realizing
that she can create her own reality
coming to the to
to a full understanding of what her
powers are really capable of right
subconsciously messing with her mind and
just being like you can create your own
universe right it's like she dreams it
she dreamed
everything that's going on in one
division right now and when she wakes up
she's like let's do this right and it
just like goes forward and does all that
stuff it's because of his actions
messing with her mind that she realizes
everything that's going on that she can
do
all this crazy stuff and so that's
what's happening the question is why is
that the case because if
wanda is a perfect host for nightmare or
mephisto to enter into her or to use her
for their own ends to kind of you know
cause all kinds of chaos and madness
throughout the multiverse
what better way to do that than to mess
with her mind in a dream
to basically help her realize what she's
capable of so she can achieve the life
she's always wanted and then take it
away or she has to destroy it herself
that at the end of wanda vision she has
to basically destroy this reality she
created for herself
she loses it all right vision's gone her
brother basically she has to watch him
go back and die again
it's all done for the purpose of
breaking wanda that she's already on a
knife stage right i mean
you watch the show when you realize
she's just she's one bad day away from
just wiping out all existence right so
like she's already on a knife set she's
already you know one half step into
crazy if they can just
push her over the edge a little bit more
then that's when wanda snaps
and that's when all measure of
self-control totally goes out the window
she's at her weakest and her most
vulnerable and that's when they strike
that's when they seize control of wanda
and wanda becomes you know the host for
them or they you know she
she gets manipulated by them or whatever
the case is whatever the end goal
is that mephisto nightmare is trying to
accomplish they need to break wanda this
one last time in order to make that
happen and that's the whole idea behind
wand division
that we look at it from this perspective
of is her coming to terms with the loss
of her brother and the loss of vision
and all that kind of good stuff and it's
like her going through the five stages
of grief that's not what's going on at
all right
that's not what's happening at all it's
breaking her and that's why you see
these small things happening along the
way of the show where she can't control
certain things right because the more
that she realizes she can't control her
reality the more frustrated and the more
angry she gets and you see that she
couldn't get her kid to stop crying you
had that stork that showed up that she
couldn't make go away it's just these
small little things that
that take place now what agnes has to do
with all this i don't know and if i'm
being honest i don't think agnes has
anything to do with any of it right
maybe she had some kind of encounter
with nightmare mephisto or maybe they
said like go get wanda bring her to us
you know bring her to me
and then like you know whatever it is
because they had a pact i don't know how
agnes fits into this but i think that's
what's going on
as far as evan peters and aaron taylor
johnson i think that might be the huge
reveal in episode number six that wanda
looks at quicksilver
and she sees aaron taylor johnson but we
as the audience see him
as he really looks which is evan peters
it's all just going towards breaking her
so she can be possessed and then used
for whatever it is they want to do if
she really is that powerful if she
really is
creating something out of nothing she's
violating the laws of physics she's a
walking talking infinity gauntlet if
that's what it is then yeah it makes
perfect sense so let me know what you
guys think down in the comment section
i'm really excited to hear your ideas on
this punch holes in this theory punch
all kinds of holes in this
and uh yeah we're gonna bring this to an
end guys make sure you guys check out
our playlist for the wanda vision
theories and easter eggs and so on and
so forth and i will catch you all later
peace